what's up everyone welcome back to the
collider interview Studio at Fantastic
bestest 20123 I lucky enough to be right
next to Weston ruli who made an
incredible feature directorial debut
riddle of fire congratulations thank you
thank you so much you've had quite the
ride with this one thus far oh yeah I
hope you are prepared for this question
this will be the hardest question I ask
you all day can you give everybody a
brief synopsis of your movie just in
case they don't know about it yet short
yeah so riddle of fire is uh I call it a
Neo fairy tale um it's a action
adventure comedy about four little kids
in Wyoming uh who ride dirt bikes and
have paintball guns and are sort of like
these Terrors around the town um they're
kind of like goblins and they're on a
little quest to gather the ingredients
for a blueberry pie for their sick
mother so it's kind of like Hansel and
gredle Little Red Riding Hood but on
motorcycles and with paintball guns I
was thinking that this was a hard film
to synopsize and actually give people
the feeling of what it was but I feel
like that did a pretty good job oh thank
you I also walked out of this movie and
immediately wanted to go buy a paintball
gun oh that really yeah that's like
that's the goal I really want to make
like everything as satisfying as
possible like loading you know seeing
like loading the guns and like you know
riding their bikes and like shoot like
breaking ceramic gnomes and stuff like
sa satisfaction like I'm sure it comes
from the cinematography but also the
sound design too like something about
the noise of shooting a paintball gun
gives you the feel that what's in their
hand is in yours as well and that made
me want to walk out the door and do
everything cool yeah that's I'm glad you
I'm glad you got that very much very
much all right so going uh going back to
the beginning with this because again
this is your feature directorial debut
that is a huge deal and should very much
be celebrated so you wake up one morning
you say I want to make a feature film
what did you think was step one to
getting a green light at the time and
now having done it would you recommend
that step to another filmmaker who wants
to make their first feature um I don't
the word greenl doesn't really apply
to my me or like my type this type of
movie I mean it's as Indie as it gets um
I I mean it took me a long long time to
like kind of I don't know I I completely
raised the funds myself and put it
together uh I mean it's like yeah this
is Indie as it gets when you are raising
the funds for a movie yourself what's
like the first the first piece of
funding or thing that clicked into place
that made you think like this isn't just
a dream that I'm whipping up myself but
this is actually going to happen yeah um
I guess when there's certain people
bigger bigger people that were like
attached to certain film festivals that
promised me large amounts of money once
I had secured like 80% but so like those
were very exciting I guess which they
problems um ensued after but um yeah I
don't know stuff like that um but it was
really like P piece by piece by piece
and it's was a hard long road so I don't
know if and then you know and then we
shot the film for like half the budget
so it's like it wasn't really it never
got fun or easy until like it was
excepted until until it was done and
like you knew it was going to screen for
people I feel like that is the story
that a lot of uh film whether it's a
first feature or not I feel like that
story is often the repeat for every
single film you make yeah I don't think
so I think the next one will be easier
we've already got some it's like funding
and stuff so I like I like hearing that
I like hearing that when you come out
the gate so hot and successfully I feel
like you deserve at least that little
bit of ease yeah thank God it's like
yeah it's it's it's good okay so you
directed some shorts and music videos
before you made this feature so can you
maybe pinpoint something about those
directing experiences that came in handy
here but then also maybe a learning
curve that you experienced making your
first feature yeah um I mean every any
chance you get to shoot anything is is
great because it's just practicing and
practicing but um a lot of those were me
learning uh shooting on film on on 16
especially and that was definitely and
working with my DP that I work with on
riddle so getting used to like the work
relationship and workflow with him and
shooting film and that um so you know
learned mostly a lot of that from
shooting those things um learning curve
for
feature um God I don't know um it's too
much too many things I guess
everything um you brought up 16 so I'll
go there next because I I feel like many
are encouraged to shoot on digital for a
whole wide variety of reasons so I don't
know can you maybe pinpoint something
about shooting on film that maybe would
intimidate people but it's actually very
reasonable to do and you would recommend
them try it if that's where their minds
are going to best support their story
yeah I I would recommend it yeah I mean
it feel it's very um it really hones
everyone's Focus incredibly because you
know how special this medium is and how
limited it is and how much you have of
it um so everyone's like really really
on their game and you know every shot is
important and everything um but yeah
also shooting on film though
specifically for for my work as I love
to shoot on film because uh you know
riddle of fire is like very stylized
fairy tale movie and film is the medium
that I feel confident um with using to
pull off that stylized Vibe and to fully
like accept this stylized fairy tale
World um which I don't think is like
totally necessary for drama I mean it
all depends what you want but like I
think for this genre and this Vibe it's
like film is it really completes it from
the audience perspective it felt right
I'm glad you went that route so I was
reading somewhere that pretty much all
the scripts you've written are about
children or teenagers so I'm assuming
you had a couple of very influential uh
movies in that department that you saw
growing up so maybe maybe what is a
movie that you saw in love that you
wanted to emulate because it captured
that experience but also what is
something that you think is missing from
those movies that you wanted to make
sure yours head yeah um it's a good
question I mean I I loved uh I loved the
little Ras schools growing up and like
the actual like original show hour gang
from the 20s like there's something
really Charming about funny kids like
beating up mean adults or playing tricks
on adults um so they you know I loved I
loved all that but I wanted them to kind
of have the resources of like McCully
culin and home alone you know and be
like experts like how much he's an
expert but like him but be like
scrappier I guess and um so that's kind
of the combination I would say that
became riddle of fire I like that Vibe
you definitely feel it here um speaking
about your cast like this this movie
doesn't work as well as it does unless
you find the perfect kids for these lead
roles and they are something else did
you find that the four of them maybe had
a shared quality that signal to you like
be ready to jump in and do this yes they
did have a shared quality and that
quality was they all seem speaking of
this kind of relates to my last thing I
said but they all had uh each of the
kids seemed like Timeless child actors
that could have been equally at home in
like a a 30s uh uh little rascal short
20s 30s little rascal short or like a
70s Disney live action movie or 80s or a
'90s you know so I was like since they
all had that quality I thought I thought
that they would get along and they
they they would be able to do it which
they did speaking of the time I want to
go back to the cast but you bring up the
Timeless quality one thing that I found
really interesting in your movie is that
it does have a Timeless quality where it
feels like the story could play out in
any decade but then you also do include
cell phones and the opportunity to be
able to research on the spot did you
always know you were going to
incorporate incorporate that or did you
ever consider removing that yeah I I did
because uh for for a few reasons one of
them was because I still I want I'm I
want I wanted to have the
optimistic um you know optimistic view
of like real true fairy tale Adventures
could still happen today even with all
all what we have um you know if the
right people are right kids are doing it
or whatever uh second of all it's just
easier I mean it's it's a low super low
budget movie so I had to set it now you
know in order to avoid any like it works
issues um yeah I appreciate I appreciate
the idea of making sure that that kind
of adventure story feels still feels
possible today because it does feel like
we're moving further and further away
from that being a reality right now yeah
I guess so but I mean you know it
happens if you you know I'm from Utah
and like there's so many little towns
where you see little Moto kids riding
around like little kids like going
around with bone arrows and stuff all
can picture is my niece and nephew like
sitting like this with an iPad in front
of their face all the time scares me
scares me so much I mean if they wind up
getting creative with the devices maybe
I'll feel really feel really good about
that but yeah it's not not the same
anymore to highlight your uh four leads
here even further can you maybe tell me
something about each of them that made
them a standout actor and maybe even
called for something different from you
as an actor's director yes okay so let's
see each of them so yeah Jodie Skyler
Peters who plays jod um he was I didn't
real when I cast him I didn't realize
how how um uh hard he would be to
understand so I had to the first day of
shooting I was I was I didn't know what
we were going to do and then I had to
decide to subtitle him um which would
you know made it I was like oh yeah it
solves the problem it makes it funnier
and it's funnier cuz he's the most
eloquent one of the gang um and then he
was the one that wanted to add more
lines and so he would ask me like or he
would his mom would ask me be like is it
okay if like he said he wants to say
like when they when they when they have
the crab legs or the other kids want to
uh pray like leave the crab legs and
with the villains that Jo he wanted to
say I'm not leaving without these babies
and I was like yeah sure you can say
that um yeah Hazel um Charlie St he like
seemed like the epitome classic American
kid like Tom Sawyer Huckleberry Finn um
so yeah he fit right in uh Phoebe faroh
Alice is like she just had this like
really angsty like little kid energy
sort of like Tatum O'Neal and Paper Moon
um or or the girl from zazi Don the
Metro who those were the kind of
influence to her character and then U
yeah Laura lote who plays pedal is like
she had the funniest audition tape where
she was just like hopping around chairs
being a little fairy and she was just so
funny and like so charming and um yeah
she's she was great they're all great
yeah and they were the only kids that
got callbacks like they were the only
kids that I was like maybe they can work
and it was like yeah oh I love that
there they're really something else in
this so you you bring up the the
subtitling for for jod and I was reading
that you had a couple of other uh like
issues in the edit that you had to cut
around can you maybe name a couple of
them and tell us how you wound up
cutting around them yeah so editing this
movie was like truly a challenge because
no take was clean right so it was kind
of a Tetris game of you know what what
can cut with what like the wide shot can
cut with this you know this two shot
into this closeup and how do I get out
of that cuz you know cutting from the
wide and the closeup I can't get back to
the wide because like the continuity
doesn't mix because they're you know
they're facing the other way or
something and it was like I I don't
every scene just took like I don't know
couple weeks at least to edit like every
scene one scene took me a month to at it
which scene is that um it was the trail
head scene when they the no the trail
head when they're when they Hotwire the
car when they like it's a sort of a
longer scene there's like it's just
there were so that was the that was the
final thing we shot it was the final day
everyone was so tired the kids were so
tired and it was like it was hell yeah
we uh so that took forever to edit for
what it's worth the edit feels so fluid
and natural to me which is hugely
impressive and when you bring up the
thing with subtitling jod that feels
like the perfect example to me of
something where like maybe it doesn't go
as planned but it actually adds
unexpected magic that makes the movie
even stronger yeah I mean that's film
making you know that especially shooting
a feature it's like you got to you got
to roll with it you got to make it work
the opening Heist was not supposed to be
inside they were actually supposed to be
robbing a delivery truck that was like
showing up with the automo boxes and the
delivery driver was like moving them and
they were going to go in the truck and
get them but it was it there was a
thunderstorm and so we couldn't shoot
and it was like well there is like this
sick Warehouse in there like I like yeah
they can go like they could go in like
it could be a sick huge Heist it's even
and it was way cooler it was like way
better it looks cooler too because you
use certain techniques that I feel like
the greatest biggest budgeted uh spy
movies use so that they get this game I
love that quality I was reading a little
bit about a point system you had for the
kids I want to know which of the actors
got the most points and who got the
least points yeah Jody uh he got the
least he like didn't care or something
or he would like start losing and he
didn't care but Charlie Stover he the
Hazel he definitely W he got the most
points he was like he was like on it
yeah um but yeah that was basically like
the point system was to uh like to have
them reset the f after cutting like cuz
they you know when I call cut they would
all like want to run away and like look
at the camera like look at and other
things and but so if they whoever reset
the quickest would get a point and then
at the end of the day they would get a
prize and it was usually a prop from
that day I feel like when I see a movie
like this with so many key performances
from kids I think back to film school
where like one of the big things they
tell you is never make a movie with kids
and don't make him with animals either
having so successfully directed A group
of very young actors say what piece of
advice would you give another filmmaker
who wants to make a movie with kids but
is afraid because they heard things like
that um I would suggest writing a
something that is on the lighter side
and that is fun and action-based that
this you know cuz kids I think they're
it's it's a lot easier I get I mean
maybe I don't know at Le to direct a
sort of more fun action-based comedy
movie rather than like a dark drama with
ch that would be pretty tricky I think
they seem to be having so much fun
promote like I loved looking at your
your can photos the group photos are way
more exciting and like I don't know it
feels like more heartfelt than the
standard ones we get yeah they had a BL
we had a blast I mean it was like it was
a first thing first time for everybody
you know like first Festival first film
first can like yeah was uh everyone was
really really excited and happy and they
were having so much fun yeah big
question but because you said you're
already moving forward with your next
feature and I I love asking this because
I'm a big believer that nobody in this
business says good job to themselves
nearly enough we say it to other people
and that is wonderful but can you
pinpoint maybe something specific you
accomplished on this movie that you
could look back on and say damn like I'm
proud I pulled that off and it'll give
you confidence on your next film yeah I
mean I am I am very proud of this movie
given the resources that I had to make
it I mean it was a very very tiny budget
and a many amount of shoot days and yeah
as you said kids and it's like sag so it
was like you know you get eight hours a
day but that means really six hours and
for to for this for the success that
this movie has had I'm like it's a
miracle almost and I'm yeah I'm proud of
it as you should be for the multitude of
films out there that think they need
money money money to be able to bring
their Vision to screen can you give us
an example of a technique you used with
very little that maybe more production
should consider Taxidermy
elkhead I I don't know for the prince of
the mountain that was like we had you
know I mean for sec we're like do we do
a CGI elk and like that's not really in
the cards so it's a it was a taxy alhe
head that I was puppeteering I mean it's
kind of funny but it like it serves its
it like fits the aesthetic of the movie
I was going to say I don't know how many
movies that would actually help but now
that I'm thinking about what I've seen
here I mean kind of would yeah I guess
um yeah what else another few things but
I don't know yeah so I'm going to flip
around the other the the proud of
question that I just asked you because
you have been on the festival circuit
with this film and like that's one of
the best things about film festivals is
bringing your own film there but also
getting to see others and being able to
meet and support other filmmakers so
during this film's Festival run can you
pinpoint maybe something you saw another
filmmaker do in their movie that made
you go like like damn that is something
else and it inspires me that I saw that
oh God you know I I feel kind of bad but
I haven't really seen any movies um the
only one I saw other movie I saw well I
saw two at two at can other movies and
one of them was my w movie with Johnny
Depp Jin du which it looked super
beautiful I'll say it was very beautiful
made me very much want to do a Victorian
period Bas I guess what about any people
you've met along the way yeah I met Alma
doar um it that was pretty cool and I
met met Jim jarmush on on the red carpet
um but yeah over he was so nice and he's
like my hero I mean you know he's
probably my favorite uh living
liveaction film director and yeah he
remembered my name like later and I was
so and I showed him my C the cinema
cover and he was like it was like really
really cool those are the memories that
matter and really riddle of fire is
excellent so I have a feeling you're
going to have a lot more of those
encounters on the horizon huge
congratulations on film you thank you so
much thank you to
Collider